in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week so let's talk about
strength and muscle and I will do this
with Eunice he's a certified sports
scientist and personal trainer he at
Holmes place at the potsdamer platz in
Berlin and you say that muscles are not
only sexy to watch that muscles are like
a life insurance why is that it's very
important that during the process of
aging we keep the ability to walk walk
the stairs that we that we are able to
do everything we do in daily life and
especially for all the people it's very
important to avoid falling and falling
is one of the major issues that exists
in this in this group of people and this
is what you can avoid with training your
muscles so what kind of people come to
you not just bodybuilders know it's not
just bodybuilders it's normal people
that want to look a little bit better
and there are other people that maybe
have a medical condition and need to
strengthen their abs or their back
muscles and these people come here and
they need to work on their muscles make
them stronger and a little bigger as
well when I go to regular gym I see
machines where I can sit in - and then
you can move the machines around I can't
see any machines here just see free
weights so is it better to train with
blue lights and can you do an actual
full body workout with it yeah it is
better indeed you can do a full body
workout because you can do all the major
movements just with the barber I can
show you this with this barbell so
once us the bar yeah that's right is the
bar the first exercise is this quad so
we're starting in this position we're
going down and we come up this is a
great exercise for our lower body then
we can push the bar over the head or we
can do a rowing movement it starts like
this and we put the bar to our belly and
this is a great exercise for our back
muscles and for our biceps as well it's
actually you you don't even need a
barbell you can use something like a
trunk of tree and it can train in the
forest so if you if there is no gym
available you can just try and
everything isn't it
yeah you could do this but it's very
important that you perform a proper
exercise form and so this is something
you really need to make sure that the
exercise form is good and if this is the
case you can start with training and you
can train very effectively just with
this bar so so what can go wrong what
mistakes to people usually make when
they start body weight training or
weight training we have some major
problems that many people have and Leon
is going to show us some of these as a
trainer as well are you training sir but
now you're showing us the mistakes one
can make this is what is doing so one of
the major issues is that the knees are
going inwards and when it comes up they
are still in words and this is something
we really need to avoid the knees should
be straight right now it's going to show
us how it should look like so this is
the right form yes yeah and can you show
us we the mistake again
so yeah it's a definite look very stable
desert the knees going inward and the
food is collapsing inwards and this is a
big issue we can't put the force where
it should be and it's a problem for a
lower back area as well so another
another issue is when he goes down too
straight and the knees are coming
forward you can see this and this is a
very very and these heels come up from
the floor yes this one as well but
what's the problem if you do it wrong is
it it's dangerous for the body yes of
course you can hurt yourself and you can
hurt your spine you can hurt your knees
there is a potential potentially
dangerous but if you do it right it's
very effective strength training is a
very very good training with low
injuries so can you start without a
personal trainer have to solve this film
for instance yeah you could if you have
a friend that is showing you and
introducing you to the exercises but I
do not recommend to do a squad if you
never did it before you can start
practicing without the bar then you put
the bar and at the bar to the training
and then you can put some weights on it
and this is the way it normally goes if
we talk about performance or muscle
growth enhancing substances how frequent
is it that people use them the problem
is there and it's growing and more
people are start using these things and
they start using illegal substances to
enhance their muscle and their
performance but yeah it's a problem
we have because it causes medical issues
and it's unhealthy that's for sure but
whether you draw the line I mean it's
even taking some new routine if you run
a marathon to get rid of the pain on the
knees is it a performance-enhancing drug
what this depends on the frequency if
you need to take it every day and you
start taking it on a regular basis I'd
say this is a problem but if you take it
just for one time or after a very very
exhausting training I think this can
help and the trip you're right and is it
alright to go for some protein drinks
after work out I mean this is just
protein and some minerals in it isn't it
yeah you said it yourself just protein
and some sugar and minerals this is
completely alright to take after
training after good and hard work out
you need to give the body protein and
some sugar and this is very helpful but
you have to make sure that you do not
eat and drink too much calories over the
day but if you want to train for weight
loss it will set you back an amazing 350
calories because that's in here so is it
ok to drink so many calories after work
not well it's a right after workout
because you burned a lot of calories
there and you have to make sure that the
nutrition is is all right over the whole
day and not just look at the timing
after training if you eat very well and
if your calorie intake over the day is
very well calculated it's not a problem
at all we got a lot of viewer questions
probably as Trish CEPS wants to know how
she wants to get a six-pack and she
asked if doing crunches is enough well
I'd say it's not enough there are many
many studies and scientific research is
showing that the plank for example or
other exercises where you have to have
core stability are very effective for
getting good apps and for training your
abs in
good way and this is what I'd recommend
not do all the crunches you can go more
the stability part of training
we got a viewer question from Vietnam is
it efficient to do strength training
when you grow older of course it is and
you can start at any point of your life
even if you're 60 years old you can
start because you probably have 20 years
left and then you have 20 years of
training left and in 20 years you can
achieve a lot and you can get stronger
you can look better you can get more
healthy and this is what is possible at
any time of your life a viewer from
Brazil wants to know is it okay to do a
warm-up or is it necessary to do a
warm-up before strength training of
course is necessary there are three
steps we need to warm up and to prepare
our body for exercise the first step is
raising the core body temperature and
the next step is to prepare the joints
we're gonna use during the exercise and
third step is prepare the muscle you're
gonna use and this is we do this with
lower weights and doing the specific
exercise we're gonna use an hour work
out and this is a way to warm up and
prepare your body properly if I want to
start strength training now and I want
to have some six-pack broad shoulders
nice pecs how long does it take before I
can see some results usually it takes
about four to six weeks to see the first
results but you have to make sure that
your training is good and nutrition as
well but if you want to achieve your
goals and the body of your dreams you
have to consider that it takes one or
two
maybe three years to achieve this goal
because all these things are taking time
and do not give up just keep going and
keep training and will achieve what you
want three years before I get the body
of my dreams great thanks for this
answer you wanna thank you so keep going
but don't do it so hard in the beginning
because there's risk that you could
injure yourself
[Music]